hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
chemical microscopy with coherent raman
scattering
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's scientific talk is brought to
you by labyrinths and sponsored
by leica microsystems for more
information on our sponsor
please visit leica microsystems.com
our first presentation today chemical
imaging
for biomedicine the next frontier of
light microscopy
will be given by dr wei min of columbia
university
following dr min dr vulgar schweigart of
lyco microsystems
will be presenting on crs microscopy the
leica
sp8 cars srs system and applications
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will be conducting a
live q a
with dr min at the end of his
presentation a live q a will also follow
dr
speichard's presentation due to time
constraints
any questions we are unable to answer
during the live event
will be answered via the email address
you provided at the time of registration
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or you can use the
ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
i would now like to introduce our first
presenter dr wey min
of columbia university dr minh graduated
from peking university in china
with a bachelor's degree in 2003. he
received his phd in chemistry from
harvard university
in 2008 studying single molecule
biophysics
with professor sunny z after continuing
his postdoctoral work in the z
group dr min joined the faculty of
department of chemistry at columbia
university
in 2010 and he has been a tenured full
professor since 2017.
dr min's current research interests
focus on developing novel optical
spectroscopy
and microscopy technology to address
biomedical problems
for a complete biography and doctrine
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen thank you for
joining us today dr min
you may now begin your presentation
thank you christy for the introduction
and uh good morning everyone i'm very
glad
to be here today online to share with
you
about the exciting research along the
line of chemical imaging for biomedicine
so i'm associated with chemistry
department i'm also associated with
biomedical engineering and the brain
science at columbia university
so let me start when it comes to
biological imaging the contrast
mechanism
is mostly important so if you think
about it
when we go to hospital we go to
hospitals we have particular emission
tomography
pad and the magnetic resonance imaging
mri
those are extremely useful for medical
diagnosis but those
medical technologies are not
particularly useful for basic
research the primary reason is because
their spatial resolution
is too coarse to not be able to resolve
individual cells
so if you go to the other extreme then
electron microscopy
or x-ray tomography they have extremely
high spatial resolution from the single
atoms they can see
molecular structures however they are
extremely
invasive they're not going to be able to
do uh with live cells
so that's why optical microscopy is
unique
in that is that it can have
high spatial resolution in the same time
you can
interrogate live biological samples so
that's the reason why
two nobel prizes have been given to the
development of
optical microscopy in particular
fluorescence microscopy in the past 10
years
one is development of a green threshold
protein another is development of super
resolution fluorescence microscopy
so those are those fluorescent
microscopy
now open to fluorescence microscopy the
main topic we're going to talk about
today is actually vomit spectroscopy
with raman microscopy
so unlike fluorescence which requires
the electronic transition to the amino
fluorescence
or aroma scattering you just have
instant light
coming in to interact with the
biological
sample or voids of composite
chemical bounds then the chemical bound
migration will scatter the insulin light
into different colors so if you
select all those scatter light and
disperse it by a
camera then you will be able to collect
so-called raman spectrum so shown here
in the below is a raman spectrum from a
biological sample
of bacteria as you can see here you got
very rich
chemical information here you get the oh
from water
ch from lipids and protein and then on
the left hand side you see this
very crowded fingerprint region if you
zoom in
you will see many many small peaks each
peak represents
a distinct chemical group so you can see
that chem
raman scattering raman spectroscopy is
very informative
in getting all this chemical information
that's why robin
has been extremely useful in uh
sample categorization in material
science and chemistry
for that reason rama himself one of
their price in the 30s
now when it comes to imaging converting
a raman scattering process
into a microscopy is not a uv thing
so in the market we have the so-called
spontaneous raman scary microscope or
ensure this rather microscope they use
insulin light
to interrogate the sample and then the
scatter line will be collected
and analyzed by spectrometer so this is
how regular raw
microscope works it works fine
but the problem is that it's extremely
insensitive so just put it in
perspective
it's about uh 8
to 14 orders magnitude
weaker than fluorescence and
therefore it takes extremely long time
for example it takes hours
if not days to acquire a
raman image of a three-dimensional
biological sample so it's not really
ideal for
most of the demanding biological
applications which requires high support
and
fast time rescuing especially on live
samples
and and because uh you also excite all
the fluorescence of
most of the tissue so how to separate
stem
fluorescence from raman you need a lot
of post processing and the background
correction so
that is also a non-trivial things to do
so basically the the thing is raman
spectroscopy the basic aroma scattering
indeed can work for biological samples
but
in many many cases it's not ideal it's
really
not really putting this raman
spectroscopy into the best
performance so what i'm going to talk
about today
most of my time is going to be this new
modality called the similar development
scattering as you can see from the
cartoon here
is really a combination of robots
gathering
with stimulated emission from einstein
so
for those of you who actually have a
physics background you might
recall that the steaming mission is how
laser works so laser is the equity
for immune stimulation radiation
by uh light amplification through skin
emission radiation so
that's why laser can be so strong
because of the amplification from skin
ignition
by the same reason if you combine raman
scattering with skin emission
the joint effect could amplify the
signal a lot so in the
two in the energy diagram shown here uh
compared to the spontaneous rama the
regular rama in on the left-hand side
so the stimurama use another beam you
can see here there's a
additional stimulated beam from the
right hand side
and the energy of that beam matches with
the energy of the
uh uh remember any difference of the
pump and the energy
and the stokes will match with the
energy of the vibration omega here so
when that happens
the joint action of pump and the strokes
will
excite the vibration mode much much more
efficiently
than the spontaneous raman case so
quantitatively you have equations here
you can see
the rate the r the rate of stimulation
meaning the rate of vibrational
activation
versus the rate of spontaneous warmer
is on the order of 10 to the 8th
so meaning a similar robot actually
amplifies
or accelerates the vibrational
transitions by
more than eight orders magnitude so that
explains a lot of the
advantages of stimuli
now so how do we detect so here is the
key
slides to talk about the physics so
on the left hand side you get pumping
slopes like coming in
interacting with the sample and then
once the interaction is
finished one vibrational mode will be
excited to excite his face as you can
see there's a little
uh little ball going up to the excited
state
and on the same wall in the meanwhile
the
punk which is the blue photon will be
destroyed emulated and the meanwhile
one new photo will be created into the
red folk spin so basically three things
happen at the same time
vibrational excitation of the molecule
one loss of the pump photon in the
pumping
and the one creation of the new spokes
photon in the stone state so three
things happen at the same time that's
the physics
of the stimulum and
if you look at another way here is the
intensity of the input from the forks
beam
on the on the left you can see they are
equally
their equal height once they interact
with the sample the output spectrum
you can see stoke speed will decrease a
little bit
delta i is called the stimulant gain
because those new photos are created
into the spokes fingers i just met
a minute ago and then in the meanwhile
this
photon well pumping intensity was anyway
little bit it's got the other ip
it's called the stinorama loss srl
and because the pump beam photon is lost
so
so you can see that the intensity is
actually changing
after interacting with the sample and if
you notice on the
right hand side omega aes there's a very
small peak
it's called cars so the cars is also
generated
in this process and it's generated at
the new frequency
anti-stop omega as and it's uh it's a
very small
magnitude so we will come back to that
in fact you know as you know that cars
microscopy has been
has been around for decades and the
people just extract this car
signal and use that for microscopy so i
will come back to that in a moment
so this is what microscope look like so
because we use pump strokes beams we use
uh two lasers one is bomb one is both
they synchronize together
and then they are brought together
focused together into a microscope and
then
the sample after interacting with the
sample is collecting the forward
direction
or the backward direction by condenser
and then filter out and then
and then collected by photodiode now the
key problem
here is that the signal we are detecting
is a little tiny
steel raman gain or experience on my
last signal so the signal is on top of
the laser
therefore laser noise laser has
intrinsic fluctuation
so that has to be taken care of the way
to take care of that is by using
modulation so you can see
in this diagram there's a little
modulator in the spokes thing that turns
the soaking on
off very fast as you can see from the
uh columns see here the bottom
of this slide once those is being
modulated on off then you can imagine
that the screen environment signal
gain or loss will be also modulated on
off
so if you modulate say 10 megahertz
signal will be also marked as 10
megahertz now
if you see the noise diagram in
b you can see that the noise as a
functional frequency is actually going
uh going down very rapidly so once you
go across
megahertz or 10 megahertz then this
laser mode
is pretty much vanishing all you have to
have is channel's limit
so that's why we tend to modulate really
fast to get away with this
one over f low frequency laser noise
no now this is the modulation part and
because we modulated the photodiode
needs to be extracted by locking and
printfire the locking and profile will
lock at this modulation frequency so
if you modulate at 20 megahertz locking
will be
locked at 20 megahertz basically it's
synchronized between the modulator and
the locking
and that will allow us to only extract
the signal
not the laser noise so this is really
the key
technical uh i would say innovation
of sr's microscopy compared to say
fluorescence or clocks
so presidents don't do this cars
microscopy doesn't have this only sls
microscopy has this modulation
line locking which is the key uh
electronics
to the surface to this technology
all right so uh i think uh
you will hear from the next part so
leica now has an integrated system that
put
everything together including the laser
microscope electronics so
you will hear more about this commercial
system in the next talk
so now let me give you a little bit
background about
what we expect from this type of
measurements so first i would
talk about the micro spectroscopy so you
can see that
because the signal is generated by the
mounting interaction between the pump
and strokes so signal is mean in respect
to
stroke spin and a menial respect to pump
pain
so you can see there's a linear
intensity curve
and then the spectrum is identical so
you can see three
curves here between
red green uh sorry red blue and the
black so the those are spinning around a
lot
in the roman game and spontaneous drama
from maximal solutions so here just to
show that
the spectrum spectroscopy of spin
environment gains miranda loss
is identical to the
spontaneous vomit which gives us the
capability to do spectral analysis
in a very convenient way and
finally the concentration curve so here
is the methanol concentration
you can see about five to ten minute
molar uh with
a very short time scale so again the
sensitivity is
mean the signal is meaning respect to
concentration so we have very nice
quantification here
it's linear respective pump mean
respective slope
mean respect to concentration and the
signal
or the spectroscopy is identical to
spontaneous
[Music]
now that's the attraction what about
imaging so
shown here are this uh and these are
really this is actually 12 years old
data it's one of the first sr images we
took
in the lab so when we tuned the laser to
regiment with the
ch stretching you will see nice lipid
images from skin from the cell showing
the liquid droplets
and then once we tune off the ch
showing on the right then if you go to
the
bottom that goes to the edge of the ch
peak then you see nothing
basically there's a huge uh vanishing
of the signal when you go uh between on
resonance
to off wrestlers
so that's basically this is really the
very first uh
demonstration of sr's images
now i mentioned cars so i think uh for
this audience today
i just feel it's important or it's going
to be helpful
to uh compare the
features between cars and flights or
there are many differences
so on the fundamental side cars is a
parametric process
meaning the molecules are left on chain
open direction
it's a full wave mixing so in the
terminology of physicists
and uh and as i see the
energy transfer between the light and
the matter
the energy transit between light and
matter so
by that definition there is an energy
transfer between those two
materials that's basically all going to
be active so cars
is not detecting the energy transfer
cars is detecting
so for a mixing generated car signal so
those are the fundamental
differences now practically what does
that mean
is that for spectroscopy cars is
proportional to the third order
nonlinear additive
square so it's called chi 3 to the
complex modulus
squared and for ss it's
only determined it's only proportional
to the imaginary part
so this is getting technical but
basically what this means is actually
sis is actually proportional to the
spontaneous problem
so spontaneous well-known if you look at
the physics
it's also proportional to the imaginary
part of the factory so this is
why when when you compare cars and
athletes background they're another
thing
okay car spectrum is not the famous
style spectrum
whereas sli spectrum is the same as
contains around the spectrum
so that's your physical meter and the
third
the concentration dependence so i just
showed you ss is
meaning whereas in cars exactly
somewhere between media and quadratic
so this is somewhat a little bit
complicated because the
cars depending on the concentration
again
depending on the background because the
cards also will have this so-called
non-resonant background so that's the
last thing i'm going to talk about
charles has a non-resident background
meaning even if you don't have
vibrational resonance
the electron of your molecule will still
be able to generate
this parametric processes giving you the
car's
so-called background and whereas this is
not
existing in srs so ss is free from
non-random background
i think those are the key issues and for
this reason
and i would say the coherent raman
community has reached a consensus that
most of the applications we have so far
especially for biological
sls is superior superior because
he get rid of the background and he
doesn't need to worry about the
concentration dependence between media
and quadratic
and it has this a nice uh identity
with spontaneous spectroscopy so here
i'm just going to show you one example
because
i think it's easy to show with the
picture
so this is exactly the same sample
exactly the same thing
now you can see for ss on the left the
all investments and
off residents unrest even all resonance
is brighter but
off residents still give you this sound
residual non-wrestling background
whereas if you do srs unravels gives you
this
nice signal but when you turn off
wrestling the background is gone
so this is done by exactly the same
sample as you can see the pattern so i
think this this picture yellow
illustrates the advantage of ss
in doing uh in imaging because it gets
rick get rid of this non-rapid
background
all right so i think i've spent enough
time on the technical side
so for those of you who want to read it
more so my group have
written and published this review
article in nature message
earlier this year uh
with the title biological imaging of
chemical bonds by stimulus carrying
microscopy so this is a
rather technical
depth so you talk about a lot of
technology and application
and so it actually covers a wide
variety of topics in biological
applications including cell biology
lipid biology microbiome tumor violence
in neurobiology developmental biological
pharmaceuticals
so you're very interested in these
individual areas so i
highly encourage you to look into this
review
and they also talk about instrumentation
development
so uh for example the latest the video
rate imaging
the very rapid hyperspectral excitation
even super resolution single molecule
volumetric
in vivo imaging so many of this uh
high-end application instrumentation
development have also been included
in this review so i think it's a good uh
resources to look into so um
now my my remaining heart will be mainly
spent in
major applications so i would say
ss has a major application in in my view
at least three main areas for biological
at least three major areas
so first is label free i think everybody
now appreciates the importance and
advantage of label for you indeed this
is exactly what we envisioned
when we first published this paper in
2008 as you can see that the title
of the very first of the very first word
of the title very first
word of the abstract is all about lego
free because at that time we believe
this is really a main
advantage compared to other say
fluorescent techniques
now this is one of the good example of
labor free tissue imaging
of a skin tissue here is a it's a
v-stack
i just point out that we can do
z-sectioning without any pinhole for the
same reason why uh
two phone fluorescents can do dissecting
without people because it's both
non-linear signal the signal is only
generated at the base of focus whereas
intensity is the highest
and uh
and this is besides tissue we can also
do label free imaging of phase small
molecules such as retinolic acid
it has a very strong raman peak around
the 1600
and say dmso it's a popular small
molecule
carrier so you can put these two
molecules together into the scheme
you can you can have the three color ss
16 gives you the red
the blue gives you the retinoid acid the
green gives you the dmso so those
three colors can be done by label-free
mod 3 color
imaging very readily
and we can also do say lipic imaging of
more animals organs organisms such as
the
theatrical so we can do this in
comparison with
more traditional uh
plc and gc but advantage is that we for
athletes
only need a single war so
um you don't need the bulk
uh sample size of samples if you have a
dynamic capability of monitoring your
situ as a function
of time and they can be quantitative
with a high spatial resolution
and chemical composition so this is
actually now becoming a very popular
uh research tools in in this
model animal research field
in the uh another example of tumor
images
from uh sun shield uh scoop and you can
see from title it's a rapid label-free
detection of human
uh uh brain tumors you can see from this
picture
if you just look at the fly field you
don't see much of differences but if you
use sls you can see the huge
differences between the tumor and normal
tissue
so there is a day-night distinction you
can clearly see the boundary even with
single cell resolution so this
is very useful for medical diagnostics
uh
by your label freeway so i just
slow this picture through this example
here this is not biological but
but it's also label-free showing we can
look at ions
so very recently we collaborate with the
collaborator we can see how ions
move around in the vicinity of the
electrodes in a working battery
so this is going to the material signs
as well but i think the point is that
because it is a label-free and we can
see things that
fluorescent cannot see and we can see it
without any label it creates a lot of
new research opportunities so
i think i basically have i hope i've
convinced you
or you've already been convinced that
laboratory is a major area
for uh applications of sos
now in the remaining time of my talk
uh another 25 minutes or so i will be
mainly talking about
two new research areas or two new
application areas
that i believe uh raman or ss
can be really helpful can be really
advantageous
so here i just showing you this slide
from fluorescent community as you can
see that
fluorescence is really great because
there's a lot of reason but i think
one of the major reasons for why
fluorescence is so
powerful is because they have so many
different
versions of probes you get
organic dyes you get the gfp or
different version of different colors
with different photos which will
properties
you get quantum dots so you can have so
many different functions
for fluorescence to harness so i was
quite inspired
by this uh general
strategy so i was asking myself when i
get started as an assistant professor
but what can we do well what can we gain
if we introduce
problems into rama we're going to excess
microscopy specifically so i think
in the past 10 years my group had been
really pushing on this i think now the
field has
uh has uh agreed that this is actually a
very
good forward direction so i will show
you two
two main uh areas which i believe will
be really useful
for biological research so first it's
about
small molecule eugene so here's the
slide showing the
typical organic typical of fluorescent
probes in terms of their size
so jv is about three nanometers in x and
y
anybody is about 10 nanometer quantum
dots about 10 nanometer and the
organic four versus smaller but they're
still a nanometer or so
but you can compare all of those things
to small molecules
such as glucose who are amino acids
they're just
way too big so here we're going to put
in other words
if you want to study small molecular big
interest putting a giant
fluorescent probe it's most gonna it's
most likely gonna
destroy the small molecule function so
our strategy is to
dramatically shrink the size of drops
from fluorescent probe
to a vibrational probe the vibrational
probe can be made
in only two or three atoms so you can
engineer those atoms white wisely enough
you can create a new color a specific
color and you can track
this vibrational probe therefore you can
track the label small
molecule species so this will be a
general strategy
to study small molecules in large
systems
so one of the first is uh actually alkyl
alkyne is this problem called triple
bonds as you can see this is a dna base
labeled with triple bound you can see
the spontaneous has a very nice
peak in the 2100 wave member regime
which is sitting in the middle of
nowhere which is so-called silent
region you can see there it gets very
crowded fingerprint
it was cf region but in the 2000 red
number region
is basically nothing and the ca such as
common problem triple bond is sitting in
the middle of that
so that gives you very high sensitivity
and specificity
and with sls with 100 microseconds we
can usually detect about
200 micromolar so that's model sensitive
so if we
uh if we could increase the timeless if
you could uh
increase the acquisition time would
actually even go even lower with this uh
sensitivity
so so here's the slide showing you can
use the alkyne to label pretty much any
small molecules dna based rna based
amino acids choline analysis
fatty acids and then put them together
we can see how these molecules get
once this molecule get inside the cells
how they
uh perform their biological functions
so here's the typical uh images we're
gonna get
so this is a knee so for example this
arm that is
dna labeled alkaline will get into the
newly synthesized
dna and this fatty acids will get
incorporated into triglycerides in the
lipid droplets all of those things can
be captured
by sns microscope so just give you
an example this is immunization dna if
you tune on you see
there's a nice nucleus and if you tune
off the pvc
black so that tells you these chemical
specificity
and we can do this while the cells are
alive
so we don't need to fix or kill the
cells we can do live cell tracking
and we can do this with brain tissues
in you can see this regenerating neurons
in brain slices and
also knee generate regenerated new cells
new cell development in the developing
embryo
of the zebrafish and this is a glucose
so i think we all heard that glucose is
very important
as an energy source but the traditional
methods require this radioactive label
which
is polymeric emission thermography which
do not give you the spatial resolution
so we synthesize with glucose analog
coupled with this alkyne and then we can
see
how this molecule is being uptaken by
cancer cells neurons and brain tissues
so this is the images showing you the
heartache connectivity
of these alkyna blood glucose so i think
this can be very useful
for study basic glucose metabolism
and for tumor i think uh
here you can see label 3 shows you this
boundary between tumor and healthy
tissue but not very clearly but if you
look at the
alkaline chromos very clear contrast
on the left is very active uptaken but
on the right hand side it is an acrylic
area
which means the tissues are by so it
doesn't have much of
a glucose optic activity anymore so
another example
uh on the bottom again if you look at
liquid protein
you see some differences but not a whole
lot but if you look at alcoholic
recording
again the choline metabolism is hugely
different
between those two areas so this gives
you a very
new dimension of metabolism compared to
the traditional lipid and label free
all right you know drugs again we know
that drugs are small molecules
mostly and we can put a alkyl in the
drug
and this is actually a fda-approved
anti-fungal drug which
itself contains an alkyne uh triple bond
in the
structure so we got this from cvs we put
the crane out of the tube and then put
this uh crane on the
mouse here because this is the skin drug
and we wait for this
drug to penetrate through the skin for
half an hour then satisfy the mouth cut
the gear out with it under the
microscope we can see the penetration of
this drug in 3d
how you get how it gets from the
structural cornea all the way down to
such uh subcutaneous fat you can see the
penetration pathways of this drug
in the tissue so recently we
collaborated with the
grand stocktails group who work on the
anti-cell death pathway
and they're interested in this
particular is called serostatin drug and
we basically modify the drug by adding a
conjugated alkyne
into the structure and then we can see
how this drug
gets enriched in different parts of
organelle inside cells
so you know previously people don't know
the
um they don't see the drug basically
they don't see the drug they don't know
where
where it's uh where where it's at and
now we can see
you know the physical location of this
drug in life cells
and so i told you a lot about this
alkyne and in fact
deuterium is also useful in many ways
and uh it's a very classical way of
introducing carbon deuterium into the
molecule
and we realize that for some of the say
metabolites such as amino acids we can
enrich a lot
so if you put the carbon deteriorate
into the amino acid side chain then the
notice is that protein will be enriched
and then by looking at carbon uh cbd
stretching uh which is also happening
in this uh styling window then you can
really
take a picture of the newly synthesized
the protein in the cells
and they're showing here and if you
block the
translation then the signal is gone so
this really gives you a measurements of
the neutron proteins and where and when
they are made
inside cells and tissues so this is the
brain
cell of a and if you look done kind of
almost see the synaptic
uh concentration so this could be a
local protein synthesis and contract
spines
and if you look at the culture the brain
slices
again the green color tells you to
loosen that protein to get
highly abundant in the uh
dental gyrus region which is known to
have very high metabolic activity
and uh fatty acid is another example
where you can put a lot of
carbon hydrogen a cd in the side chains
and with that you can actually see
the difference between the saturated
versus
unsaturated fatty acids so i don't have
time to get into but we actually spend a
lot of time
working on this problem of uh how
saturated fatty acid is different from
unsaturated fatty acids it turned out
that you know if you just look at the
images there
they are night difference so for
unsaturated they go to the
droplets this is the little white dots
for saturated they go to this endoplasty
reticular membrane and screw up the
function there
so i have a paper years ago to talk
about
the biophysics differences and this is
really because we can
now using this cognition to track
the uh location and movement dynamics
of these data inside black cells so it
was very short
you know we can really see how they how
they actually modulate
the uh membrane and inside life cells
so uh we also did uh some of the
physiology studies for example
there's a model called the
traumatic brain injury tbi where the
brain tissues get stretched out to mimic
the effect of brain injury and then we
use
our deterioration or alkaline liquid
metabolites and then
it co-incubates this brain tissue to see
after before after injury how the
metabolism of the brain is
different right so we see actually very
interesting results just to give you one
highlight the living metabolism is
hugely
upregulated after the brain injury so
especially the skilless region in the
campus
is more than 10 times higher
activity compared to the uninjured case
so i think this methodology is
is useful uh to look at metabolism in
general
so um so i just want to end by showing
that
we have actually a review article to
talk about this normally
on some molecules and here there's a
small table showing
the molecules we and others made
in uh getting this uh uh labor
tax you know this is probes into the
small molecule including cholesterol
google et cetera and so i think this is
about growing very rapidly as a new
field
for people interested in small molecule
metabolism
and just to finish up by saying that we
can also do this in the
animal case but in annual case there's
actually a
trick we can do this that is instead of
feeding animals with different type of
drugs we can just feed them with the
determined label water so heavy water
it turns out that heavy water will be
able to incorporate into different
biomolecules such as dna rna
carbohydrates proteins lipids
and when they do they the resulting
the the resulting
period lip glitter in the protein and do
the raspberry and they have different
spectrums you can see from the left hand
there and that is
the basis for us to spectrally
distinguish them
so we can then do spectral analysis to
figure out
how much and where those municipalities
the protein dna
and the lipids are inside inside cells
and
actually even entire animal tissue so
here's just one example where we harvest
the tissue you can see
the muscles that's the lipid on the
green channel and using the protein
of the red channel so different tissues
different tissues and if you just zoom
in the brain you can see that
you know the brain cell with in the
early stage and the later stage you have
a very different
lipid synthesis activity that there is
the signature of manipulation
in the brain development region so we
can capture that
appearance and if you look at the tumor
region then again very clearly the
tumor has a high activity in
protein and lipid synthesis whereas the
healthy brain tissue is
much more quiet in that activity so we
can
use this to highlight the boundary of
the tumor and also
be able to highlight the heterogeneous
uh
pattern the hotspot hot regions inside
in that tumor
all right so i think so that's so i just
finished the second major application
that is a small molecules related either
cells or tissues or animals now
in the remaining 10 minutes or so i will
talk about
the third region the third area
which just has something to do with the
systems biology or omits
but we all appreciate the biology is
complex at all
time scales and all length scales so
anywhere you look at there's so many
interacting
uh interacting players that you want to
study
so if you just study one player at a
time
that's not gonna give you the whole
picture in fact that's gonna give you a
lot of misleading results
so that's why complex biology requires
multiplex technology so i think that you
know the whole biotechnology
community have already reached this
consensus
but the problem is that the fluorescence
message is not
a intrinsically high multiplexing
technology
so if you look at its lessons you can do
full color
if you are good you can do five to six
if you really push it
but you're gonna hit a barrier because
you know no matter how you do it the
spectrum is going to overlap so no more
than five colors can be said it can be
simultaneously
uh imaged so this is called color
barrier of fluorescence microscope
but if you look at rama in comparison
you will immediately recognize and
appreciate the importance of rama
because
it is actually almost 100 times
narrower than fluorescence spectrum so
in that regard
if you could you know engineer ramen
dyes or ramen drinks and then put a lot
of them together
just like this you know different color
fluorescents then you should be able to
offer many many more colors than what
fluorescents can do so
in 2014 we started this journey so at
that time we have this alkyne
and then we using isotope carbon 13
to replace carbon 12 then
because you add more mass into the
triple bounds you actually slow it down
right just like any mechanical
oscillator
the animal mass will slow it down that
creates a new frequency so
you can add one carbon 12 uh one carbon
13 you slowly down from
green from blue to green yeah two of
them you slow down from
green to red so by doing that we can
create three different
three different uh um
three different colors and then by three
different
if you label three different small
molecules you can actually create three
different
uh patterns of small molecules again so
this is the first time
that we are somebody are doing
multi-colored raman imaging of small
molecules
but now that only have three three
colors so that's not uh enough to do
this uh extremely high
multiplexing so uh we
realize that in order to do so we can we
can actually use
uh you know organic for organic dyes
directly
so we developed this electronic
pre-resonance stimulant microscopy
which to say what is to say that if we
if the
molecules start to absorb light and then
the laser
is getting up close to that we actually
could enhance the sensitivity
dramatically by fighting orders
magnitude
so previously just a simple alkyne
only give you a hundred micromolarity
but once we
start to use you know dyes then
for example you know studies when the
typhoid and vitamin dies then the
sensitivity go up by 500 magnitude now
we are going to the netherlander region
so as a proof concept you can see that
we can use this dyes and label tubulin
and then we can use
the mana contrast to generate
their to look at their contrast so this
is the first time we actually use rama
to look at an individual protein in this
case tubulin
imaging in a biological sample now so
this is the
this is i think this is significant
because you know
all the previous images were taken by
fluorescency meaning of the guys
now this is done by rather sr imaging of
the
from a very sharp peak
very sharp peak of course just relying
on the regular
commercial dies not enough so my group
have been really pushing the development
of our
our own diets or our own mother acting
guys
so here in the 2017 we showed that we
can do this
planar structure and 2018 which is so we
can do
the linear structure and we look at the
spectrum they're all very
distinct engineered so each of the
monitor has a very sharp peak
and then by engineering the structure
this peak can be
flying tuned step by step and then
they're all
well separated and on the right hand
side for example this
combo from the rainbow you can see as we
go along
all these little molecules have this
nice bigger can be all
pile tickets so now we have 20 colors
from this bubble that allow us to do you
know in principle 20 color imaging
simultaneously
of course now this is like the guys
we'll have to really you know
work out the protocol for biological
applications
so we're pushing in several runs and i
think all of those things are
very exciting especially in the new
uh era of assistance by owner you
were all mixed where we had to look at
many many things at the same time
so just give you some of our latest
results
so those carbon dioxide will be able to
target specific organelles with protein
inside lifestyle so here is example of
10 color imaging
10 simultaneous pink color images in
black cells
so even though you are looking at 10
different separate small images they are
actually the same cell
and they are capturing the same cell but
it was 10 different contrast
at the same time so there's a thing
called imaging in your life cell which
is
the record in lifestyle imaging in terms
of the color
and then we can also you know combine
this with flow cytometry as you know
that fluorescence fellow technology is
extremely powerful but again the number
of colors is
still limited so here just to show our
progress
on population results we can hook up
with antibody
and then we can use our ramen dyes to
label the uh labeled antibody then we
can look
target five different membrane proteins
in the live cells and then
by looking at the spectrum we can see
five distinct peak so
so you can see this is very it's very
easy for rama
uh in general to get uh multiple colors
uh because the spectrum is so sharp so
it's just
so we're just at the beginning i'm doing
this and now tissue limiting of course
is a very huge market because the
immunostaining
is is essential for many
areas of research and medical
diagnostics
so here is just an example we can do 12
color imaging of tissues
is very good contrast now and so we can
hook up our
hookah raman dyes to those uh secondary
or primary antibodies and do the mineral
thing
and this is the trail color put together
of the same brain region and then once
we start to do single cell analysis
we can do the so-called correlation and
that correlation with piece mean
plot just to get all the high
dimensional data
into uh into good understanding so
i think now we're really using this as a
systems biology approach
and uh we can also put this to large
volume of samples so i'm sure you all
heard about the recent
development of volumetric optical
clearance which allow you to clear the
entire tissue
to optical clarity but
they are still relying on fluorescence
so again the number of colors they can
extract is
limited so we are combining the
volumetric large scale issue clearance
with our srs
approach so we published a uh
first step to show that we can do label
free srt medium with water electric in
the game so that's published
last year and recently we're pushing
this
for uh super multiplex imaging so
this is actually a 12 color imaging of
a very thick uh brain tissue
of uh so i will i believe this is the
first time that
you know so many colors can be extracted
from a
very large biological sample
but also push for high resolution such
as
super resolution and the way we are
doing is to
push it with expansion microscopy so
i'm sure you know the expansion
microscopy can expand the samples
therefore
uh succulent the diffraction limit so we
are doing that
and we are coupling potential microscopy
with our
uh super multi-clocks and we can do now
at least
seven color imaging with expansion
microscopy
so i think i think this cartoon just to
say that
we have several you know areas to push
and uh one is you know spatial trans
high high sensitivity high spiritual
resolution
in the live cell or middle ss or a whole
organ
body that gives us this body magic or
spatial resolution the super absorption
so
if you put those things together if you
think about the sweet thing together
high spatial high temporal and the
entire
volume that is really the goal of
holistic imaging
we really want to be able to measure
almost like as much as possible you know
in terms of the volume in terms of the
spatial computer
in terms of the number of targets we can
measure
so that's what my group most of my group
is
going after at this stage so finally
the last one minute or so i just want to
touch upon the ultimate sensitivity i'm
sure
audience will be interested in knowing
what is ultimate sensibility so
uh one you know short answer is
we can do single mark so we can combine
volume excitation
with fluorescence detection because most
of the dyes we are looking
looking we are working on is actually
also have fluorescence emissions
for example size 365 loading et cetera
and
if we couple ss excitation with
fluorescence detection we have the
so-called stimulant excited for essence
that will give us the ultimate single
molecule sensitivity so we demonstrate
that
again last year in major photonics
showing this spectroscopy can be done
and we also show we can do a single
molecule
because i mean it's hard to do it but
it's not that surprising because we are
using fluorescence detection that
give us the ultimate sensitivity so if
we really need it so basically if
the application is so demanding that we
have to have single molecular
sensitivity we can do it
but with the stimulant robot excitation
so the spectroscopy is still
raman by nature but the sensitivity can
get down to a single mark
so with that i just want to i think i'm
pretty much
uh no i think this builds up all my time
i just want to end my talks by
thanking the group who has made
tremendous
contribution to the uh to the project we
just
talked about together with a number of
collaborators both living and
uh outside columbia so
that's it so i'm happy to take more
questions
if you guys have
dr amen thank you so much for your
informative presentation
as you mentioned it is now time for our
live q a portion of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for you have
some great questions already coming in
dr min our first question roughly
how long does it take to acquire an
image
of your live cell probes for example the
do modified
small molecules okay so
the time i mean it's gonna depend on the
concentration
and the sensitivity et cetera but
typically i would say typically
the image is about 10 seconds for those
clothes
it's about takes about 10 seconds or 5
12 by 5 12 pixels you start it takes
about 10 seconds
if the sensor if the 12 is really strong
it can be less than that say
one second so i think the bulk part is a
few seconds is our bulk part
very good thank you our next question
can let's see can ramen have
good contrast of neuron dendrite
axon to background
environment have good contrast
uh i guess
by contrast of what of neuron
dendrite axon to background
oh okay so um i think
i think yes at least in the paper we
published we clearly see
neurons and and
i mean the processes are harder to see
but if you do mean
we can definitely see it it's a little
challenging
i will say but um it's my experience
it's actually doable
very good what is the maximum thickness
of tissue
you can analyze
okay so for traditional
standard stuff the tissue we okay
i guess the question is that the
penetration the light penetration is
limited if the tissue scatters the too
much so that's about a few millimeter
and for the optically cleared tissue
right now we're doing we can clear up to
two or three millimeters
and for the so that's optical clear so
if you don't clear it
i think our typical penetration depth is
about two or three hundred microns
so so if you don't do anything you can
image from the top all the way to 300
microns
that's about it that if you clear you
can do two millimeters
thank you dr min our next question
how much light intensity is experienced
by the sample and what laser power is
required
to perform srf
okay so the power on sample okay here is
the thing you know we are using
like i think all my images are done by
six picosecond laser which is uh
produced by this ape company also six
picoseconds
is rather long compared to say seconds
into photo excitation so because of this
the longer pulse
so the follow damage etc is not that
severe so we are
we often use relatively higher power for
the six
picoseconds compared to femtosecond
pulses
so for applications i listed which is
kind of challenging we're using about 50
megawatts
so five zero so that zero milliwatts on
sample is what we typically
use um if the symbol is brighter we can
use it
slightly less if the sample is less
brighter we can use
say up to 80 to 100 milliwatts
so it sounds a lot but the in practice
we have you know done this for 10 years
i think uh
cells actually are quite okay with the
six pico effect
and we realized that if you shrink to
two picoseconds or
say 200 some profession then the
difference is dramatic so the shorter
the pulse
the less power the cells could handle
thank you now next question dr min
are there any groups working on moving
pre-resonance
enhancement into the visible and uv
range now this is several parts do you
expect this to give a
similar sensitivity enhancement for
molecules with
uv absorbance maxima
uh i know yeah so um
my own group have published a paper
showing we can do this with red
red dye near infrared that we can do
this with red dyes
xi jin chinese know that boston
university has also shown that he can do
a red dice so red is not visible that
has no problem
i think there's a group in china who is
pushing for
blue sos so they double the light to the
400 nanometer region
to show they do blue so
in that regard i have no problem in
believing that all this visible range
has no problem so
uv okay uv i mean in principle you know
there's a lot of people doing uv
spontaneous rama so you should i mean i
would expect
uv srs it's also possible but again
there the
the damage could be more severe so i
don't know whether
doing uvsis would be better or worse
but that's an interesting question to
try
so you know physically in terms of
physics
this is all worked out so i mean there's
no there's no reason
why they don't work in uv or visible
rain it's just a matter of
you know whether you have proper probes
you know whether the light
is damaging the sample and that kind of
practical questions
very good thank you so much for that
answer now dr min when alkyne is added
to turbinating
does it change the solubility and the
drug uptake
from the skin so the turbinating itself
is actually
containing alkaline so that block so
that blood itself
contains alkaline already so in other in
that
in that sense we are not really adding
it it itself contains an alkaline so it
doesn't really change anything
it's a native drug by itself of course
i showed another drug uh this uh
cell death drug then uh the alkynes
added
it uh from extra and you can see that we
did we did it in a way that we also
modify the alkyl structure to have a
hydrophobic tail
so all of those things because we want
to maintain the negative solubility and
the hydrophobicity of the drug
so um long story short
um if you just add the alkyne you will
actually change a little bit i mean
it depends on how sensitive your drop is
so
in a way we actually try to you know not
just adding alcohol we're adding a
little bit more like
a ch3 group stage two groups to uh
help to modulate the hydrophobicity so
if that drop is really that sensitive
so that's the strategy we're working on
very good now we have time for a few
more questions
our next question since the stimulated
emission
is coherent would you expect to see
interesting interference effects that
depend on the orientation
and location of the emitters
uh yes skimming emissions coherence spin
rama is coherent
and to orientation of the generators
okay so
i don't think so because first of all we
never seen this nobody has ever seen
this kind of thing in the literature
playing this for 10 years another reason
is is coherent
but you also interfere with the infant
being
so it's a it's a so-called heterodyne
it's a headache processes
it's like absorption so put it this way
the
ss detection everything is really like a
meaning absorption
so in absorption if you expect this
i mean i don't think the people would
typically talk about the emitter
orientation interference from the
absorption measurement because that's
already
interfered with instant light this is
again different from cars different from
car cars
each emitter where you meet and they
constructed or destroyed interfere
that's why
in cars you actually see some of those
fringes
sometimes something very strange that is
depending on the cohering effect but for
absorption type of measurement linear
absorption or ss
in general this kind of thing is all
absorbed
because of the already interfered with
infant light
thank you dr min is there a way to
sacrifice spatial resolution for better
sensitivity
oh yeah of course so we are doing some
of those things in our tissue imaging so
we don't need
say 100 nanometer if we if we uh if we
expand our beam to cover say 1 micron 2
micron at the same time we put more
power in
actually the power density is actually
even lower but
we are interrogating more molecules in
the in the focal volume that actually
increase the sensitivity
so my students have tried and we are
currently using this kind of strategy
for
non uh you know for applications that do
not require that
that kind of high spatial resolution yes
thank you dr min and we have time for
one more question
can ramen be combined with crispr cast 9
guided fluorescent protein
imaging
uh okay i will say yes
just that nobody has tried that you know
i don't know so
i mean put it this way i think aside is
intrinsically
compatible with fluorescence that's
something that
we typically don't emphasize enough but
actually turns out to be quite
important for example spontaneous rama
is very hard to combine with
fluorescence because
as i said you get all the essence once
you have a fluorophore in the system
your spawning drama is
pretty much overwhelmed but the last
slides we never worry about you see a
lot of images we are done
we combine ourselves with presence all
the time so
in that regard i would say i don't see
any problem of merging
ss with any fluorescent technique
thank you dr min do you have any final
comments for our audience
i don't i think i think this is my first
time doing this
webinar so completely online i think
that this is a
nice experience for me
we're very happy to have you and we
thank you for your time today and your
important research
now i want to remind our audience that
we have quite a few questions come in
that we were not able to answer so those
questions
we did not answer and those that come in
during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by dr min
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration thank you
for joining us dr min
i'd now like to introduce our second
presenter dr volker schweicard
dr speighardt is a product application
manager for leica microsystems
with a background in optics biophysics
and cell biology
it is his passion to develop instruments
and procedures to probe biological
processes at the subcellular
and tissue levels at leica microsystems
he works with customers collaboration
partners and in-house r
d to drive innovation in non-linear
optical microscopy and multimodal
imaging
including coherent raman scattering
microscopy
multi-photon fluorescence microscopy
lifetime imaging
and harmonic generation microscopy for a
complete biography on dr schweikart
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr sprycard you may now begin
your presentation
dr schweikert you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you christy so uh welcome
again
everyone also from my side uh to this
webinar session
and um today i will be telling you about
vibrational spectroscopic imaging
in cell tissues and model organisms with
the leica fp8
cars srs system
so i will begin again by a
motivation on why we would be interested
in
vibrational imaging and so i'm showing
you some
example images here right to start with
and as you can note all of these images
have been
performed on untreated unstained samples
and still you are able to get this very
fascinating very rich
contrast so the real motivation behind
vibrational imaging in my opinion is
that you have an extremely rich
chemical based contrast and
of course this also comes without a need
for labeling your samples
however you don't only have to work with
label unlabeled samples but you can also
introduce labels to your system
some people are surprised to learn that
even label free imaging
can be very fast up to video rate
imaging has been demonstrated
in cell tissues and model organisms
and in addition to this really
very crisp image contrast what is really
behind
all of these images is a vast
information contrast
content that comes from exploring the
entire spectroscopy of your samples here
so in this way you can obtain spectra
like i'm showing here in the lower right
from every image pixel and this spectral
information is both
chemical and also biophysical based as i
will show you some examples
during this presentation now
as dr min has just been
introducing you to one of the exciting
coming up topics
vibrational tags so these are small
tags that are now being designed to be
able to image targets that were
inaccessible by fluorescence
microscopy earlier
so in this way we will make available
small molecule imaging using
uh spectroscopic contrast
and the last point that also dr min was
pointing out already as we are finding
out as we're exploring more and more
applications of stimulated and coherent
drama scattering
we are finding that the information that
we can obtain is really highly
complementary and it can be very
synergistic with fluorescence microscopy
so i will show you some examples of this
during this presentation as
um well to let uh all be on the same
page i want to just take a slight step
back and
get back to the basics on how we
actually excite those vibrations
using light and the basis of soil is the
spontaneous ramen effect
which happens when a laser is
impinging on a sample where the energy
of the photons is not high enough to
excite
the molecules into an electronic excited
state from which they would emit
fluorescence so in this situation all of
the light essentially is being
transmitted through your sample
and only very very rarely does it happen
that
one of the photons excites one of the
molecules to vibrate
and in this case a lower energy photon
is emitted from the sample this energy
has been reduced by just the amount of
vibrational energy that is being
deposited into that molecule
so in terms of an energy diagram this
process starts by absorbing
a photon to a so-called virtual state
and then emitting that lower energy
proton
spontaneously and ending up with the
molecule
in one of those vibrations and states so
energy has been transferred
to the molecule and so this is a very
weak process
in typical situation about one in 10 to
the seven
photons tend to be scattered so this is
nowhere near the quantum yields that we
have
luxury of in fluorescence microscopy so
raman microscopy is possible but it
tends to be very very slow
and so that's why researchers have been
thinking about ways of giving
this raman effect a boost and coherent
drama scattering is really one of the
most exciting ways
of achieving this and the way this is
done is by shining
in addition to that pump laser we
already had for the
spontaneous rama effect without shining
a second laser in
onto your our sample where the frequency
difference between the two lasers has
been tuned to exactly match one of the
vibrational frequencies
of our molecular sample so this is what
we call
vibrational resonance and in this
situation
both beams together the action of both
beams together excites the entire
molecular ensemble
to vibrate very efficiently so we're not
waiting anymore for single spontaneous
protons to come out but we're using
essentially a large number of the
protons to drive the entire
ensemble of molecules and so what we see
is that the excitation of the molecules
then corresponds to a loss of photons in
the pumping and the redistribution of
photons
into the stock speed and the changes of
the intensities of the lasers are
actually such that they can be measured
using very sensitive techniques
so this is the underlying physics behind
the so-called stimulated raman
scattering process or in short srs
so we're still exciting to a virtual
state using the pump beam
and then we're driving down the
molecules in a simulated fashion using
the second laser beam
that's where the enhancement comes from
so these processes are most efficiently
driven using picosecond
laser pulses and under such high
intensity
laser excitation also other non-linear
optical processes do occur
one of them that has been noticed very
early on was the emission of blue shifts
with photons
where the process looks like this the
first two steps are the same as in
stimulated raman scattering
but then the molecule can absorb yet
another pump photon
to yet another virtual state and from
there emit
a blue shifted photon leaving the
molecule back down in the ground state
and so this blue shifted photon is
called the coherent anti-stokes rama
photon and therefore the
entire process is called the cars or
coherent anti-stokes raman scattering
process
so both these processes occur under the
same
circumstances of excitation and that's
why they are both
combined under this umbrella term
coherent raman scattering
and they both share this characteristic
that the vibrational resonance of the
two laser beams is really
what gives this process its chemical
contrast so in other words we have two
photons exciting
a chemical vibration so it's a
multi-photon optical contrast
that we are using here and so we can
couple those two
laser beams into a laser scanning
microscope and in that way we have a
imaging modality that we can now exploit
for microscopy
so the way we now use this
or we can use this as a spectroscopic
imaging
technique is to acquire a series of such
srs
images at different vibrational
frequencies sequentially
so we are tuning the frequency
difference between the two
lasers and at each tuning step
we are taking one image so we first take
an image at one vibrational frequency
tune the laser take another image tune
the laser again
etc and in this way we can acquire an
entire spectral data set
of this sample what i'm showing here in
this case is an untreated piece of apple
what you can see in the lower left part
of the image is the peel of the apple
and what you can see in the upper right
is the flesh of the apple
and so now we can go in and pick certain
regions of interest
as shown here in color and we can
display the entire
vibrational spectra of these
regions of the image and you can see how
dramatically different those spectra can
be depending on different chemical
compositions of those compartments that
we are looking here
and then from this basis data set
the user would basically define their
downstream analysis and pick out the
pieces of information that are contained
within this dataset
so i'm showing you here what we can do
one very simple way of dealing with this
huge amount of information is so-called
spectral unmixing
so here we have taken the spectra that
we recorded
from those regions of interest here and
taken them as a basis
to unmix the signals from the sample and
so in this case
we were able to unmix up to eight
different
chemical components or biochemical
components
of this sample and those very nicely
correspond
to some of the known biochemical
structures of the apples so here i'm
showing you the
outer layers of the cuticles or the
cuticle proper and then different
cuticular layers we see some
different cell structures here and then
we see
the flesh of the fruit the cell walls
and we see certain pigments such as
chromoplasts here
and all of those different areas have
a very different spectroscopy so the
outermost layer
we can see those series of very very
sharp spectral
peaks and they indicate an almost solid
phase of
long chain fatty acid molecules that
actually correspond
to the wax layer that protects the apple
from drying out
now if we just move a few microns to the
inside
the spectroscopy looks very different
already you can see
some of these peaks become significantly
smeared out
different peaks appear and
what this kind of spectrum signifies is
typically a fluid phase of
unsaturated fatty acids such as for
example oleic acid so you can see a very
clear difference in the biochemistry of
these different layers
of the apple and then we can go on and
on and look at the different
regions here the polyphenolic compounds
that tend to give apples their health
benefits they appear to be found in
those compartmentalized structures here
just beneath the peel
and then as we move to the flesh you see
a different spectroscopy where we can
identify polysaccharides and then
in pigment like structures we can see
keratinos
so this is just to give you an idea of
the amount and
kind of information that we have
available
from those kinds of data sets
now this is the instrument
with which we at leica are able to
access
all of this information it's the fp8
cars
um confocal microscopy system
with srs add-on so this is like us
hands-free stand-alone
solution for coherent drama and
scattering and so
if you're familiar with confocal
microscopy you can see the sp8 confocal
microscope in the front here
and in the back this is the addition
that really enables the coherent raman
part that's the laser source
that emits those two laser frequencies
that are able to access those chemical
vibrations
and in terms of a beam diagram we have
it here so this laser source is called a
picosecond
optical parametric oscillator it emits
two laser beams one being tunable and
the
other one being fixed both of them in
the near infrared
spectral range and those two beams are
overlapped in space
and time and focused onto the sample
from where
the coherent anti-stokes raman signals
are emitted in the forward direction but
also in the backward direction and we
can detect them
both in the forward and backward
direction
and the new addition to our system now
is the
emulated raman scattering detection
scheme where we collect those
stimulated raman signals in the forward
direction
and then process them with a lock-in
amplifier and then display the image
information just as well
like a micro systems we have a
standalone hands-free standalone
system that allows us to do both visible
confocal fluorescence microscopy with
the added
modalities of coherent anti-stokes raman
scattering and stimulated drama
scattering
on top and in addition we can record
second harmonic
generation signals as well as two photon
fluorescence signals so this is really a
multimodal imaging platform that can
combine various pieces of information
on your sample and combine them to
really extract out
maximum information content from from
your subjects
and so at this point i would like to
point out
some differences between the two
modalities that we have just discussed
the stimulated raman scattering and the
coherent anti-stocks
brahman scattering and this is the
reason for actually introducing the
stimulated raman scattering as an add-on
to the
cars system you can see here on top and
at the bottom images from the very same
sample that i just showed before
and you can see that the stimulated
raman scattering really makes available
all of the chemical information that is
present in the so-called fingerprint
region
of the vibrational spectrum whereas in
the
cars modality a lot of this information
is overwhelmed by
what dr weimin already introduced
earlier the so-called non-resonant
electronic background
that is not containing any vibrational
information
so the modalities really are
complementary to one another the
srs produces rama and like spectra and
it produces
quantitative signals where signal
intensity or peak height
peak strength is proportional to the
local concentration
of molecules by contrast this is
for cars we have great abilities to
image very abundant species
as you can see from those very strong
peaks in
the right part of the spectrum but we
have
this non-resonant electronic background
that sometimes masks signals and can
make
quantification of signals somewhat more
cumbersome
and in addition we have a non-linear
signal dependence on the concentration
of molecules
so quantification is really somewhat
more involved
so those two modalities really are very
complementary to one another in that
sense
now with that i really want to move
right ahead and show you some of the
application areas that we have tackled
with
our system and i want to begin with
multicellular model systems in the
context of cancer research
because it really highlights some of the
abilities that are key
to doing vibrational microscopy here so
what we
are looking at here is a tricellular
model system for skin cancer that was
provided by
colleagues at the university of manheim
here
and so they have specialized in
generating model systems containing both
cancerous cells
as well as cells that resemble the
healthy skin
sort of the environment in which the
cancer cells would live
in the actual patient
and so what we can see here is three
different types of cells and
i'm showing you three different signals
here in yellow i'm showing you
stimulated raman signals of the total
lipid content
in magenta and showing the unsaturated
lipid content and in scion i'm showing
you simultaneously recorded second
harmonic
generation signals and those second
harmonic signals
tend to come from things like
extracellular matrix or collagen in this
system and you can see that those are
very uniquely localized to a portion of
the
of the spheroid here so this already
tells us approximately where the
fibroblasts are located because these
are the only cells that are actually
able to produce collagen
in this cellular system
and now what was really surprising to us
when we first took those images was
that there appears to be a fourth
phenotype a very rare subset of cells
that have become very lipid-rich
and therefore show up as very bright
yellow cells in this image here
so these are cells that neither we
expected nor the researchers that
produced those samples had any knowledge
of that they existed
and so this is of course a great
opportunity for us to
look deeper into what is this rare
phenotype of cells
and to characterize what is going on
here
so now i'm showing you um really the
virtue of being able to do
three-dimensional imaging on those types
of cellular systems i'm going to play
the video again
so we have by this virtue that we are
talking about a non-linear image
contrast here we have
three-dimensional optical sectioning
that allows us to take three-dimensional
image stacks of such
three-dimensional samples and so with
this high-resolution image information
we can now begin to test
very interesting hypotheses about what's
going on in this sample so one example
of such a question is what is going on
with this unexpected fourth phenotype of
cells does this for example correspond
to infiltrating
melanoma cells that are infiltrating
into the core region of the sample
and so to test this we took simultaneous
or
correlated images of stimulated raman
scattering of the total lipid content
where we would expect those cells to
show up as very bright cells
and at the same time we took images of
the fluoresce of two fluorescent stains
that the researchers introduced
to label two of the three cell types
that are present in the sample so
melanoma cells in green
and keratinocytes in red now if we look
at the co-localization of those three
different signals
we can see that yes there are some
infiltrating melanoma cells that have
migrated into the core of this spheroid
structure
but these do not correspond to those
lipid rich cells that we saw in the
previous slide
so there seems to be a clear disproof of
the hypothesis that this lipid rich
phenotype corresponds to infiltrating
melanomas
but what is really the most exciting
aspect of this research
from our perspective is that we really
could verify here that srs
is possible without any significant
crosstalk
even in multi-color fluorescently
stained samples so this really
opened our eyes to the opportunities of
being able to have
fluorescently tagged samples where
the fluorescence would basically
highlight some kind of molecular
information
about the sample whereas the coherent
raman
imaging would allow us to look at the
biochemical composition
the metabolic state of the sample lipid
metabolism so very complementary
information that is now accessible from
those two imaging modalities
so with this i want to explore a little
bit deeper what we can do with the
spectroscopy on those
types of cellular systems so here i'm
showing the entire fingerprint
spectrum of different lipid droplets or
lipid rich regions
of this sample and you can see those
different lipid droplets give
very clearly distinct raman
or stimulated raman spectra and thereby
signify
highly distinct biochemical compositions
of those lipid droplets
and so i want to just highlight a few
specific peaks here in this
example so this peak at 1740 wave
numbers
corresponds to esterified lipids and it
turns out that those are found in high
concentrations only in the fibroblasts
within the cellular model system
now the second and third peak from the
right here
um they are very well known from
spontaneous raman community to
basically allow us a raciometric
quantification of the degree of
unsaturation of the lipids
in those numbers because the left peak
is a peak that is found
in all lipids where sdp gets 16 40 16
50 wave numbers in the peak that is
specific to the unsaturated lipids only
so just by looking at the slope of those
diagonal of those lines here
connecting the two peaks you can see
that the degree of unsaturation in those
electrophiles is highly distinct between
the two
between those different cell types and
there's
various other pieces of information here
for example there's a peak
down here at about 700 wave numbers that
is specific to cholesterol
so we can verify that cholesterol is
present in high concentrations in the
fibroblasts only the other
cell types don't produce it as much and
there's other peaks
available here and the sum of those
peaks should really provide
highly specific information on the
different cell types so we should be
able to do a
label-free discrimination of cell types
in such a multicellular
model system of course this is not
enough we are interested in really
getting into disease relevant
applications here
so we begin to look at the response of
those
cellular systems to pharmaceutical
treatment so the
doce here that's the chemotherapeuticum
and we're looking at untreated steroids
on the left versus treated spheroids on
the right
and we can see very clearly
morphologically that there are
differences going on so we see
dividing cells on the left so that looks
like healthy cancer cells they do what
they're supposed to do they divide
and on the right we see other signatures
we see the nuclei being fragmented
in those cells and this is typically a
signature of apoptosis
and so what we're really visiting or
verifying here is that the melanoma
cells can go from
proliferation to apoptosis after they
are being treated with the drug
so that's very nice we're making use of
morphological information here
but we have of course much more
available to our disposal we have the
spectroscopic information that can tell
us something about the metabolic state
of those cells
and so we're looking here at differences
of the spectral information in untreated
spheroids versus steroids that have
undergone
treatment with chemotherapy and we can
see some
very interesting differences here so it
looks like there's a decrease
in this peak that signifies the
unsaturated fatty acids
there seem to be increases in peaks or
that are associated with saturated fatty
acids so it looks really like the
melanocytes are doing something in
response to that treatment
and there seem to be some difference in
the other cell types as well
possibly an up upregulation of
cholesterol in the fibroblasts
the key information that we really take
from this is there are
differences that we can observe as or
after we administer a drug
and so we think that this really points
the way to
future applications in drug screening in
looking at
modes of action of different drugs in
potentially studying pharmacokinetics
and dynamics in such cellular model
system or potentially even in legal
or in tissues and so this really opens
up a whole new area of pre-clinical and
translational research
on disease mechanisms in our opinion
so with this i want to shift gears
to a second topic that we have studied
very intensively
with our system this is in the area of
neurodegenerative disease where
we have a collaboration with the german
center for neurodegenerative diseases in
bond
and they supplied us six unlabeled mouse
brain slices
about 100 microns thick that's how they
look in real life
and this is a tile scan image of the
lipid content
in such a sample so what we can see here
is the
cortex region of the brain on the top
and then we can see those very bright
regions here that would signify
that these are very lipid-rich regions
so this is called
the white matter region and we can see
individual myelinated neurons
projecting into those white metal
bundles so there's really highly
structured information on those tissues
available here
now what we really want to focus on in
this type of sample is
um pathological structures that we are
observing here so these
regions that i've marked with circles
those are lipids associated with
pathological structures
and i will convince you in the few
slides to come
that these are amyloid beta flux that
are at the heart of alzheimer's disease
and so here is a high resolution zoom in
of one of those pathological structures
and i will keep playing this z-stack
movie
over and over again so what i'm really
trying to show here is that we have high
spatial resolution information available
both on the healthy
parts of the tissue where you can see
those myelinated
individual neurons
[Music]
moving in three dimensions through this
tissue we can see
the dark regions corresponding to the
neuronal cell nuclei and cell bodies
i'm showing a second channel here that
we acquired in parallel auto
fluorescence coming from
little vesicles inside the nooks inside
the neurons
likely containing a leap of
three-dimensional information we have
three-dimensional information available
on those pathological structures
that clearly tells us that there's a
lipid-rich
halo surrounding a pore of these
structures that is devoid of lipids
and we want to now use the spectroscopic
information that we have available
to figure out what is going on
biochemically
and possibly biophysically in those
samples so here's a spectra from the
regions of interest shown
here in this middle image so
we can focus in on one of the peaks here
that really already contains a huge
amount of information so i will blow up
this
this peak here this is the amide 1
vibration of
proteins and you can see here that
there's a frequency shift between that
peak
in healthy regions of the brain tissue
compared to those pathological
structures there's about a 10 wave
numbers
frequency shift here and if we look at
the images taken at those two
vibrational frequencies
we can clearly see that there's a large
void
in the core of the structure at the peak
of the healthy
might one mode and there's right
fibrilla
structures appearing at the peak of the
shifted
amite one mode and this frequency shift
has been known from spontaneous raman
work to be a signature of
misfolding of proteins into a beta sheet
configuration
what we're really seeing here is a shift
that corresponds not to biochemistry
but to biophysical information and
we can use this shift to our advantage
and take a ratio metric image of those
two vibrational frequencies and by
looking at the
intensity ratio we have a very clear
label-free
signature of misfolded beta sheet
proteins in this brain tissue and it is
well known that
the famous amyloid beta that is at the
core of alzheimer's disease tends to
form
beta type structure when it aggregates
into
flux so what we are seeing here is a
label-free visualization of amyloid beta
plugs in alzheimer's disease
and this has been reported by other
groups
already earlier and just
very recently studied in more detail by
sunny cheese group
as well and we just put out our own
story on bio archives so if you're
interested in the details of this story
feel free to take a look at this at this
article
and we of course won't stop right here
because we just looked at one peak we
have a whole lot of other biochemical
biophysical information available here
in those spectra
and so i'm just going to show you
information from these two
very weak appearing peaks down at the
very low end of the
vibrational range of frequencies in this
spectrum
and so if i blow this region up
we have two really significant peaks
here um
one is at 707 wave numbers corresponding
to a breathing
vibration of the sterile ring in the
cholesterol molecule
and another one just shifted by a few
wave numbers
corresponding to vibrations of some
membrane lipids
including spheromangolin and
phosphatidylcholine
so if we look at the images
corresponding to those two vibrational
frequencies
we can see a very distinct localization
behavior of those two
chemical compounds so cholesterol is
enriched very strongly in the healthy
white matter regions at the top of the
image
but it is not very strongly localized to
those pathological structures
by contrast those membrane lipids appear
to be recruited to those pathological
structures
where they don't show up so strongly in
a healthy white matter structure so we
really have a very clear
way of verifying a distinct localization
behavior of
different biochemical species in those
brain tissues and somewhat surprisingly
we found that cholesterol does not
localize to those amyloid beta plugs
so with that i want to
walk you now through a little bit
quicker through some additional
examples that we have
that we have here so organoids are a big
area that
we think will benefit highly from
stimulated raman scattering microscopy
these are three-dimensional cell
assemblies and we can show
here that we have high resolution
information on the proteins and on the
lipids in those
structures if we overlay them we can get
very nice
subcellular localization patterns of
lipid droplets within these
three-dimensional structures here
and we can use this to our advantage to
characterize the organization of those
organoids to possibly look at metabolic
markers for the differentiation state
of those cells within those model
systems
and in the end what we really want to
look at is insulin production we think
that these
large lipid droplets here are really
precursors to insulin secretory granules
that are produced by those types of
cells but it turns out the
differentiation state of those cells is
not yet sufficient they are not mature
enough to actually produce
insulin but this is again something that
we are very excited
to looking at in the future we can look
at organoids also in
life settings so this is a time-lapse
movie of a gastric
organoid supplied by researchers
from university college cork
and what you can see here very nicely is
we have no bleaching
um this movie was
taken over several hundred frames and
there is no virtually
no change in the signal strength here
compared
to what you would get from for example
fluorescence microscopy
so what we can very clearly see here is
the very nice epithelial organization of
the tissue we can even see some
specialized cells such as these cells
here that are
very protein rich we think these are
cells
um and this is really um opening up the
way
to study those epithelial type tissues
both in
such in vitro situations as well as in
actual tissues
we can take it a step further and go to
actual model organisms
so as an example i'm showing you here
the protein content in an
unlabeled zebrafish and we can go beyond
just
simply looking at proteins so this is an
image of the intact eye
of an intact zebrafish so you can see
the lens you can see the different
layers of cells in the retina here you
can see lipid switch
regions you can see the protein
protein-rich regions corresponding to
the cell bodies
the outermost layer here this is where
the photoreceptors are localized
and then you have the encapsulation of
the eye that is marked here by very
strong second harmonic signals
so very rich contrast also in
intact organisms we can see
individual red blood cells in the
vasculature here this is a region very
near the heart
and we have more information we can look
at the colon in the individual cells in
the colon region
we can see these triaded muscle tissues
so very rich
information on on the morphology and
biochemistry in such model organisms
another very nice application example
actually is
the research area of osteogenesis so the
formation of
bone so these are
researchers that supplied us
ex vivo skull tissues
so you can see here and i just want to
go very quickly through this
again a nice example of such multimodal
imaging approach here
so these are tissues that are have been
labeled with or they express and cherry
in the osteoblast so we can get a very
nice
visible confocal image of the
osteoblasts here and then we can add to
that
the additional non-linear imaging
modalities we can look at second
harmonic generation
showing us the localization of the
collagen content and then we can look at
the
hydroxyapatite this is the actual
mineral that's forming the bone
and then in addition we can look at
lipid structures here
and we can get a very nice overlay that
shows us
the structural organization of bone
tissue that is just in the process
of forming of course we can look at
plants as well this is an example of the
famous arabidopsis taliana root again
co-localization of fluorescence images
in this case
two photon fluorescence images with
the srs stimulated raman scattering
signals of the protein content in those
samples
but again i don't want to stop at the
all well-known
aerobics sample we can also look at more
fancy things here so this is
being from germany something very
interesting looking at beta assets in
hops cones so this is the stuff that
beer is
made of so i'm showing you here some
actual images of the lupine ground
glands which are
the ones the structures that contain the
bitter acids that make up the taste
of beer and so this is the corresponding
srs and two photon fluorescence signal
here and these are down in the lower
left these are the actual nuclear glands
containing
the bitter acids and we can take spectra
from different
instances of those structures and we can
see a very strong
heterogeneity here indicating to us that
there's maybe a maturation
process going on where different
biochemicals are being produced
as a function of the maturation of those
plants and so we think really that this
could be a way of monitoring
state of agricultural plants and samples
or
more generally analyzing food samples
for their biochemical content of course
we can do solid-state samples as well
these are data not taken by us in-house
here but by one of our customers at the
university of helsinki
they were looking at pharmaceutical
tablets
and they were able to use cars
microscopy in combination with second
harmonic
generation signals to identify up to
four
different crystal phases or
including an amorphous phase of the
compounds that are present in those
tablets
and this kind of research is very very
interesting for pharma research because
the
crystallization state or ideally the
amorphous state of
active ingredients is very important for
their solubility and for the actual
delivery
to their targets so this is going into
the direction of
controlling formulations for their
quality controlling
for storage effects like heat and
humidity how they change
the the state of the sample so there's a
lot of information that can be gained on
solid state samples as well and so with
this i want to
wrap up and summarize one more time
where i think
the major um directions are going to be
that we're going to see applications
of coherent drama scattering i think um
there's plenty of evidence
now that preclinical and translational r
d will benefit greatly from those new
imaging modalities and also from
really combining all of these different
imaging modalities with one another
the visible flow resonance coherent
raman signals
second harmonic signals auto
fluorescence
this can really get give us new
directions in a range of diseases and
understanding disease mechanisms
pharma i just talked about compounds in
in formulations but of course we can
also look at the distribution of
compounds in cells and tissues
so this is where some of the raman
tagging approaches
are going to come in very handy and i
think we are going to
observe huge increase of number of
publications
on studying mode of action and
distribution in tissues
in a label-free fashion fell in tissue
biology will benefit as well we can now
do metabolic imaging we can
begin to explore differentiation states
of cells
i think we can even begin to look at
phenotypic screening approaches
in label free settings
i think neuroscience can can benefit as
well
there have been some very very
interesting applications coming up in
the recent
years that can now be combined with
label-free imaging of the biochemistry
of the brain as well
plant and food biology of course will
will be
benefiting a lot imaging of model
organisms
is possible and lots of applications
have been
demonstrated already the areas of
materials science and macro fabrication
have been lagging behind a little bit
but we've seen some examples in in dr
waymin's talk that this is
certainly going to be coming up in the
future as well
and i want to mention them separately
aromatags we really think that this
could be a paradigm shift in optical
imaging
where dr weimin has mentioned the
multiplexing capabilities of those
types of tags in addition to the ability
to look at small molecules so those are
really very
complementary to fluorescence microscopy
and all of this
really goes along with the trend that we
are observing from
producing pure images towards going to
actual quantification of image data that
is
very amenable or that coherent raman
scattering techniques are very amenable
too
so with this i want to end my
presentation
thank you for your attention and ready
to take your questions
thank you dr spycard for your
informative presentation
yes let's start our live q a portion of
the webinar
now we have lots of questions that i
have already come in but to our audience
if you still haven't submitted your
question please click on that ask a
question box
and click and uh type in your question
and click
send and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
dr spycard let's get started our first
question
how does the duration and composition of
chemical fixation affect
srs imaging specificity and sensitivity
okay that's a great question so
we haven't explored this in
detail yet what we can say
as well we have made our rule is
to allow formalin fixation we have never
seen any major effects of formalin
fixation
on the kinds of srs signals and coherent
raman signals that we get
we tend to stay away from things like
methanol
fixation they tend to remove lipids or
affect lipids
in the sample so
as far as we can tell formalin fixation
is fine and can be used
and this is something that has also been
studied in
the context of spontaneous raman
spectroscopy
so i think the findings they agree that
formula and fixation is is
certainly something that can be done
dr spiker this next question is two
parts how are the raman spectra taken
and how long does it take to generate a
spectrum
so let me jump out of my
current slide and return to the slide
that explains this so
the
[Music]
raman spectra are taken in a quite
different fashion
from what you would see with uh
classical spontaneous raman spectroscopy
in spontaneous raman spectroscopy
it would park a laser beam at one image
pixel
and you will take an entire spectrum at
that point
and then move your laser into the next
pixel
acquire a spectrum again and so on in
our case it's quite the opposite so we
acquire
one image one vibrational frequency
and then tune the laser beam to another
vibrational frequency
take another image tune the laser again
take yet another image so we acquire
images sequentially
and then after the entire stack of data
has been taken
then we can go into individual regions
of interest
and display spectra in principles from
every image pixel but the order of
operations is different from spontaneous
raman spectroscopy
now that was the first part the second
part was the
duration how long does it take to
acquire so again we're talking now about
not taking one spectrum but acquiring an
entire what we call hyperspectral image
cube so the entire spatial information
and spectral information
for an example like this one here it
would take about
half an hour to an hour typically so
that's
the the typical time frame that it will
take so something like this
is um typically best done with fixed
samples
um with a living sample where things are
moving one would have to be very careful
to avoid motion artifacts
thank you dr sprite card our next
question what is the highest
spectral resolution that can be achieved
could a frequency difference of five
centimeters to one be resolved
um so this is a good question as well
you can see in this example here we have
some very sharp
spectral peaks here those are about 10
wave numbers wide
and this actually corresponds to the
theoretical limit of resolution that
should be available in
our system because the duration of the
laser pulses
imposes a limit on the spectral
resolution that is attainable so about
10 wave numbers
is a width of a peak that is available
here
now can a shift of five wave numbers be
resolved
yes it can if you acquire a high res
high
signal to noise peak then you can
resolve the position of the peak much
more accurately than
the spectral width of your of your peak
so i would say
the width of peaks that can be resolved
is about 10 wave numbers but small
shifts
can be observed that are smaller than
that
dr speichard what objective has been
used for imaging
the zebrafish sample
um so these i believe where um
20x ir april objectives so these are
water immersion objectives with a 20
20 x magnification and numerical
aperture of 0.7
but we have a range of different
objectives available ranging from
a 10x magnification up to a 40x
magnification that we can recommend
for coherent drama scattering microscopy
i have another two-part question what
dichroic
is used in the microscope for the rld
detectors
in backward direction and what is the
transmission
range
okay so that is a very technical
question i want to
answer it from an applicative point of
view
so the question probably comes from
organizing the way that signals are
transmitted to the sample and
separating them from the different
frequency
cars signals that are being emitted by
the sample so
we have two dichroics in our system that
we use for different
ranges of vibrational frequency we have
one dichroic that is suitable for the
wave number range above 2000 wave
numbers
so this covers the entire ch stretch
region
and we have a second dichroic that is
suitable for the wave number range
between
2000 and down to 1200
wave numbers so this is suitable for
acquiring fingerprint spectroscopy
data and we have in built in our
software we automatically switch between
those
cubes depending on the vibrational
frequency that is chosen by
the laser setting so there's no manual
no need for a manual reconfiguration
except for
sustaining external cues in front of the
detectors directly
so that's the question concerning the
cubes and once more
the coherent raman spectra are limited
down
to a lower limit of 1200
wave numbers whereas the stimulated
raman
scattering spectra they are recorded in
the transmitted light direction so
there's no such
um spectral hindrance
and in this case i'm showing data that
go down to 800
vibrational frequency of 800
inverse centimeters but we can go down
to 500
wave numbers with stimulated drama
scattering
thank you dr spighard now we have time
for one more question
but i do want to reiterate to our
audience and we've had so many questions
come in
that those questions we did not answer
live today and those questions that are
submitted during our on demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the email address you provided
at the time of registration dr steingart
our last question for the day
how much average power is required
for multi-photon tpef shg
images acquired with picosecond pulses
okay that's a great question because we
get this question a lot
there seems to be a conception that
two-photon fluorescence microscopy is
only possible with femtosecond pulses
but of course that is not true the
picosecond pulses
yes they are longer and therefore they
contain a lower peak power
but they are still able to excite such
multiphoton fluorescence processes quite
efficiently not quite as efficiently as
femtosecond pulses
but still quite okay and so it turns out
that
the powers that we use for coherent
raman scattering
microscopy are actually perfectly
suitable to excite
second harmonic generation signals and
or
two photon fluorescence signals at the
same time so
it rarely occurs that we have to change
laser settings between acquiring the
cohere
drama data and acquiring these
additional
multi-photon modalities so these can
typically be taken in the same
image run
thank you again dr spycard do you have
any final comments for our audience
i thank everyone for their um attendance
it looks like a lot of people were in
the audience we're really excited to
have been able to convey some of our
interesting
research and applications to you
and hope to hear more questions from you
as
as they come to you thank you again
i would like to once again thank our
speakers dr weyman
and dr volker schweighardt for their
time today and for their important
research
i'd also like to thank the audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions
we would also like to thank our sponsor
leica microsystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
have a great day